How many continents are there on earth? If you grow up in the English world
Maybe you think the answer is obvious: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
But not everyone uses the same method to calculate.
The general definition is that "the continent is a large land mass separated by the ocean."
It's normal until you really start thinking and discovering problems.
Let's say: This kind of problem:
This is Europe, this is Asia, you will notice that there is no ocean in the middle.
Then why is this a "two" continent?
The general reason is culture: European culture is too different from Asia.
It is best to treat them as two different entities.
Oh... maybe.
But if cultural arguments are established, it is clear that India and the Middle East also apply.
Here you have nine continents and a new question: If you define the "continent" with cultural differences,
You have to endlessly add useless borders.
So some places abandon cultural differences and combine "Eurasia."
This Eurasian cannot be confused with the "Eurasia" that is fighting the East Asian countries (see "1984")
Combine the European and Asian worlds into six continents.
That side: North America and South America?
They are connected in Panama - at least in the decision of the President of Old Roosevelt
Someone has to cut this country in half and this person has to be him.
But the Panama Canal is only 13 meters deep.
You can walk through the Panama Canal from the north of Alaska.
Then, if not because of the Amazon rainforest that is full of poisonous snakes and beasts
Finally you can walk the southern tip of Chile. So although there are canals,
North and South America is not really separate. This is why some places, especially South America,
Think of the Americas as a single continent.
So the total number of continents fell to five.
But if you don’t care about the Panama Canal, you have to ignore the Suez Canal.
Create a huge "Eurasia and non-continental":
It has an area of ​​85 million square kilometers and a population of 5.7 billion.
This four-land view should be completed because
It is true that there is no continent that can be combined and it is also in line with the current definition.
Unless we are not finished yet, because of the question about "big". How big is it to be a continent?
How big is it to be a continent?
Is Australia a small continent or the king of the island?
Why is Greenland not the smallest continent? It is quite big, even if it takes off its ice.
Speaking of ice, Antarctica? This forgotten continent is unfairly squeezed under the map.
Just because no one lives there.
Take off the Antarctic ice and you will see a bunch of islands
Not a continent that was originally thought.
And in order to increase trouble, the largest land here is smaller than Australia.
So if you want to call the Antarctic "continental", there is still a pile of islands behind
Waiting to upgrade to the mainland
For example, New Guinea, Borneo, Madagascar, Baffin Island, Sumatra and Honshu Island.
When this matter seems to be approaching the peak of brain damage, after all, someone wants
Define the extent of "big" and draw a boundary for no reason.
This question is familiar to those who remember the topic of "Pluto is a planet."
This controversial fiasco (mostly) also involves size issues.
So our question is bigger than the beginning: There may be three or dozens of continents.
Do you know who can tell:
science!
Question + Science = Answer
Let us ask the geologist what the continent is.
For them, the continent refers to the plate: the part of the crust that moves together
So geologist, let us look at your continent:
Antarctic plate, Australian plate, Eurasian plate, South American plate,
African plate. It looks pretty good right now.
Medium...east plate, indian plate, caribbean plate,
Pacific plate!? Hey, there is nothing there.
"Almost" no. Nazca Plate? Scotia Plate? Are you playing really?
At least the North American plate looks decent,
Until it contains a part of Russia, half of Japan and Iceland.
This didn't help much, thank you very much to the geologist.
The core of the problem is that the word "continental" does not have a simple and consistent usage.
So how many continents do you have? So,
How many continents do you want?
Sixth, the answer is six.